hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
etwas anderen video ich freue mich total
dass ich dieses video jetzt machen darf
es ist ein wunderschöner tag wir sind
was das zeug hält sind am verarbeiten am
einfachen und kommentieren
aber die pflanzen sind nicht das einzige
was wächst es ist auch diese unglaublich
tolle gemeinschaft von besuch tief die
hier in den letzten monaten entstanden
ist wir haben 50.000 abonnenten auf dem
kanal erreicht und ich hätte nie niemals
damit gerechnet dass wir das so schnell
schaffen
abgefahren dankeschön ich weiß überhaupt
nicht was ich sagen soll
es freut mich ungemein und es freut uns
ungemein dass die videos so gut bei euch
angekommen ich sage uns weil ich das
hier nicht alleine wurde sondern weil
ich ein team habe das auch ganz ganz
ganz viel dazu beiträgt dass jede woche
die videos online gehen können zb jackie
die mir ganz viel beim film hilft und
ganz viel organisiert kilian der die
videos hochlädt und franziska die die
videos schneidet aber auch die anderen
aus dem teambus seeberg wie zum beispiel
katzen die sich jeden tag mutig in
unserem posteingang stürzt oder marie
die mir ganz viel mit der webseite hilft
wir haben ja auch den block sei zudem
noch nicht kennst du ja ein riesengroßes
dankeschön auch an euch weil ohne euch
wäre das überhaupt nicht möglich und ja
es ist super super schönen eure
unterstützung zu haben wir haben es
immer so nett miteinander aber auch
natürlich an euch da draußen ihr seid
der hammer ich hätte wie gesagt nie
damit gerechnet so viele leute sich für
die videos interessieren und es ist
immer so schön das macht mir so eine
freude die videos für euch zu erstellen
das ist einfach eine andere verbindung
ich habe davor lange geblockt aber man
hat einfach nicht so diese tiefe
connection wie wenn man die videos macht
und ich finde es auch so schön
jede woche
die gleichen leute unten in den
kommentaren zu sehen ist immer ganz
tolle samstags mit euch diese
plauderstunde zu machen und ja ich habe
im winter als ich mit dem kanal
angefangen habe nicht erwartet dass es
mir selber auch so viel spaß machen
würde also danke danke danke an alle
daraus und dass wir das möglich macht
ich möchte hier ist auch irgendwie was
an euch zurück geben deswegen verlor
sich in diesem video unten in den
kommentaren drei von meinen kursen ihr
könnt einfach mal schreiben ob ihr euch
eher für den garten kurs interessiert
also gemüse gar nicht starten wo ich
euch zeigen wie ihr euer eigenes gemüse
anbaut oder lieber den haltbarmachen
kurs haben würde wenn ihr zb schon ganz
viel erntet und wissen wollte wie man
das auf verschiedene art und weise
natürlich konservieren kann schreibt
einfach mal unten in die kommentare
welchen kurs ihr euch wünschen würde und
dann suchen wir heute in einer woche
drei gewinner aus schreiben euch einen
kommentar unter und dann müsst ihr uns
eure e-mail-adresse darunter schreiben
damit wir euch den kurs zugang geben
können ich freue mich auf jeden fall
unglaublich dass wir hier angekommen
wenn ihr irgendwelche wünsche für videos
die ich drehen soll dann schreib mir das
immer unten in die kommentare war ich ja
diesen kanal für euch machen möchte ich
möchte euch am besten weiter helfen und
das kann ich am besten wenn ihr mir
einfach direkt sagt was wir hören wollt
wo vielleicht eure probleme sind wo er
hilfe braucht und dann kann nicht
hingehen und diese videos dann für euch
[Musik]
darauf jetzt erst mal einen trinken
ich bin unglaublich oder
[Musik]
50.000 leute vor die bei uns im garten
stehen
[Musik]